Ich bin müde.
Aber noch nicht bettge, aber noch nicht bettge müde.
Ich bin aber nicht so wirklich voll dabei heute, aber ich wollte noch eine Runde Stream
Stels machen und mit euch eine Runde schwätzen.
Ja, morgen ist ganz schlecht, morgen sackt, morgen muss ich nach Frankfurt auf die Arbeit
fahren.
Glücklicherweise danach wieder Homeoffice, so Paynes Champ, Alter.
Ist morgen schon wieder Streik?
Also wenn morgen Bahnstreik ist, dann fahre ich nicht.
Bahnstreik.
Oh nee, oder?
Lull.
Donnerstag.
Der Chat erzählt wieder Mist.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass die ab morgen streiken.
Donnerstag.
Klingt merkwürdig, ich bin heute entspannt.
Ich hänge auch so auf halb acht vorm Rechner.
Erst trifft es dann den Güterverkehr von Donnerstag, dann ein bisschen...
Okay, also.
Mittwoch 17 Uhr.
Okay, das heißt, morgen ist noch gar nix.
Gehen mir so auf den Sack, allesamt die Bahn vor allem, aber die GDL auch, die gehen mir
alle so auf den Sack.
Die sollen einfach ihre Arbeit machen und mich pünktlich von A nach B bringen, der
Rest ist mir scheißegal.
Meine Güte, ey.
Was eine Riesenzeremonie wieder, Alter.
Ja, ich kann die auch verstehen, aber ich habe trotzdem keinen Bock darauf, dass sie streiken.
Nur weil man was verstehen kann, muss man das ja noch nicht gut finden.
Also die Auswirkungen.
Ich muss gerade mal was gucken, irgendwie gab es hier Questions.
Danke für den Sub eben, gab es irgendwas, der Death Operator ist wieder am Start.
Les ich mir gleich durch, also, der Umut, du bist aber auch immer am Start, oder?
Also, ein Lokal habe ich den Controller, warum sollte ich denn vermeiden, manchmal frage
ich mich echt, ob du die Fragen ernst meinst oder einfach nur eine Runde jebaiten willst.
Warum um alles in der Welt sollte ich für meine lokalen Access Points einen Unify Controller
im Internet haben?
Also, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, nein, ich habe das Lokal, ich habe das Lokal
unten im Wohnzimmer auf dem Raspberry Pi, da ist auch noch die Software drauf, die
Kamera, Überwachungs, Überwachungskamera stills macht.
Ja, aber solange die erst am Donnerstag anfangen, ist gut, da kann ich wieder Home Office machen.
Wäre bei dir überhaupt jemand da, bei mir wäre da niemand, ich weiß nicht mehr, worauf
sich das bezogen hat.
Meinst du auf die Arbeit, doch, bei mir sind tatsächlich ein paar Leute auf der Arbeit
in Frankfurt.
Es gibt da tatsächlich so ein paar wahnsinnige Leute, die da gerne hinfahren und was ich
auch lustig finde, unsere Geschäftsführer, die Stonks Manager bei uns auf der Arbeit,
die hauen wieder die geilsten Sprüche auf der Welt raus, um die Leute zu motivieren
auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Letztens hat wieder einer rumgeschrieben, so nach dem Motto, wir freuen uns alle auf
die kommende Zeit und jetzt können wir getreu unserem Motto für Menschen, von Menschen,
zu Menschen oder irgendwie so was agieren und das hat er so geschrieben, als wäre das
jetzt wahnsinnig geile Motivationsrede und ich habe einfach nur da gesetzt und so gefacepalmt
und hat mir gedacht, Alter, was willst du mir eigentlich sagen?
Diese Sprüche immer, ja und was auch lustig ist, wir haben bei uns ja mit dem Betriebsrat,
gibt es jetzt so eine, also neu ist das nicht, aber jetzt bei Corona wurde das Ganze forciert,
gibt es so, haben wir jetzt so die Möglichkeit offiziell, ich konnte ja schon jahrelang Homeoffice
machen, aber man kann jetzt offiziell quasi sagen, ich möchte meine Arbeitszeit verändern
mit Vertragsänderungen und allem und was lustig ist, sobald das jetzt offiziell war, waren
sie total überrascht vom Antrag, wo ich mir auch wieder denke, so ist es nicht eigentlich
jobs von Managern, so ungefähr zu verstehen, was passiert und die sind von allem immer
so wahnsinnig überrascht, wie kann das sein?
Können die ihren Job nicht richtig machen?
Also ich muss doch so ein bisschen, ich werde doch als Manager bzw. als bezahlt Entscheidungen
zu treffen und diese Entscheidungen sollten doch eigentlich auch so getroffen werden,
dass sie in die Zukunft, ein bisschen der Möglichkeit ein bisschen in die Zukunft gucken und gut
dafür sind, aber unsere Manager sind immer übelst schnell von Sachen überrascht, so
nach dem Motto, was, so viele Leute wollten Homeoffice machen, damit haben wir ja gar
nicht gerechnet, blablabla, warum ich mir denke jetzt, naja, der Scamtrain ist am Start,
der Mast, der Krümli, 6 Monate, massive Subscriptions hier, nee, ich gebe mir heute
bloß gar keine Mühe, irgendwie besonders enthusiastisch zu klingen, normalerweise versuche
ich ja immer irgendwie besonders so, so engaged zu sein, ja, weil ich sehe das ja auch an
in den Viewerzahlen, wenn ich einfach nur auf halb 8 da hänge oder wenn ich engaged
bin und irgendwas zeige, natürlich, kommt das besser an, aber ich sitze heute einfach
nur Vape Nation Style vorm Rechner und ich hänge eigentlich halb unterm Rechner, ok,
also der Dev Operator ist am Start und er sagt, habe jetzt ein kleines Programm mit
Pysen, übrigens die Aussprache finde ich auch geil, jeder spricht das ein bisschen
anders aus, ich habe schon gehört von Python, jetzt ist kein Witz, Python habe ich schon
gehört, Python, Python, Python, alles, alles dabei, aber Python ist das beste, die schreibt
man doch ganz anders, die Schlange, Python, Python gibt es auch noch, habe ich ganz vergesse,
Python, Python, Python ist auch gut, aber Python habe ich ganz vergessen, das gibt
es dann auch die Leute, das habe ich dann in Python geschrieben, Pyson, na Pyson habe
ich nicht gehört, C Hashtag, nee C Lappenzauen ist die beste Sprache, so also, also ein kleines
Programm mit Pysen unter Twitch, API zusammengezimmert, geht um die Nachricht von gestern, habe jetzt
nur noch ein paar Problemchen, wie gut kannst du, naja, ich habe da jetzt kein Daily Practice,
aber ich kann das lesen, ich kann das verstehen, wenn ich was schreiben muss, muss ich halt
immer nachgucken, weil ich das nicht so oft verwende, kannst du auch C Teppichzeichen,
was ist denn ein Teppichzeichen, jetzt hast du gestern schon erzählt, dein 20 Euro Gutschein
ist weg, schreib doch den Support an, habe ich doch gestern schon gesagt, ich kann da
nichts machen, wenn bei denen im System irgendwas aktiviert, verfällt, was auch immer, du kriegst
bestimmt einen neuen Gutschein, hast du, und was haben sie geschrieben, was haben sie geschrieben,
nö, ja warum nö, ach stimmt, nee im Moment, dein Gutschein war doch abgelaufen, ja gut,
da bist du selber dran schuld, wenn dein Gutschein abgelaufen ist, da kann ich ja nichts für
und Hetzler auch nicht, das steht wahrscheinlich sogar da, wenn du es einlöst, dass das nicht
unendlich handgültig ist, warum läuft der ab jetzt, das steht bestimmt da, übrigens
Leute, Ausrufezeichen Hetzler im Chat, wenn ihr euch ein 20 Euro Cloud Gutschein sichern
wollt für eure eigenen Linux VMs in der Cloud, und wenn ihr wissen wollt, was ihr machen
könnt, könnt ihr den Stream von gestern angucken, Wolle604, Dankeschön für den Sub, drin von
einem Streik ist es ja auch, dass die Öffentlichkeit Druck macht, ja, es ist ja nicht so, als müsste
man mir erklären, warum, die Streiken, das ist mir schon klar, ich find das trotzdem
kacke, ja ich hab auch kein, ich bin sogar dafür, dass sie das dürfen, aber rein für
mich aus meiner Sicht ist es kacke, und mir ist es vollkommen egal, ob es an der Bahn
liegt oder an der GDL liegt oder an was auch immer liegt, ich will einfach nur pünktlich
von A nach B gebracht werden, das ist alles, die Rahmenbedingungen sind mir, ob es jetzt
mal übertrieben zu sagen, scheiß egal, Hauptsache es funktioniert.
By the way, verwendet jemand Logitech Schmäuse, ja natürlich, was ne Frage, habt ihr noch
die Logitech Game Software oder habt ihr schon Logitech Hub, was besser, Logitech G Hub
oder Logitech Game Software, G Hub, vielleicht soll ich das auch mal upgraden, bevor ich
den Support anschreibe, dass ich doppelte Tastenklicks hab, wozu braucht man die, naja
zum Beispiel um Profile einzustellen, Software wird alles bloated, ja ja alles bloated, ich
weiß, also ihr habt alle G Hub, ihr habt gar nicht mehr die alte, alte Maus, ok, äh
die alte Maus Gaming Software, doppelte Tastenklicks ist doch bestimmt kaputter Switch, bin mir
nicht sicher, das merkwürdige ist, ich bilde mir ein, ich habe es sowohl links als auch
rechts, was auf Software irgendwie hindeutet, ich installier es neu, wenn nicht muss der
Support dran glauben, krümelst du am PC, ich ess relativ selten am PC, früher hab
ich immer am PC gefuttert, mittlerweile ess ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr am PC, außer,
manchmal sonntags, wenn ich gestreamt hab, den Stream gerade ausgemacht hab und dann
noch irgendwas gucken will, weil ich sonntags noch gar nichts geguckt habe, nachgeguckt
habe, weil ich direkt on gehe und Stream anmache, ja, übrigens ich muss jetzt nicht mehr, äh
wie nennt man das so, ja, so viele Bedenken haben, dass ich so langsam bin mit dem Chat,
weil ich hab letztes mal bei Semper Video reingeguckt, der ist noch langsamer mit dem
Chat, bin ich nicht alleine, der ist teilweise eine halbe Stunde hinten dran, hallo in diesem
Stream nur ganz kurz, so, aber er liest alle, ich lese auch mehr oder weniger alles, manches
erwähne ich nicht, weil ich keinen Bock hab drauf zu antworten, aber ich lese eigentlich
so gut wie alles, warum, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken, Custom Firmware, Leute,
wenn ich sowas bräuchte, ich bin erfreut, dass ich sowas nicht brauch, das erste was
ich machen würde ist, Custom Firmware Flashen, wisst ihr ja, ja und da muss man aufpassen,
man sollte das besser nicht in C++ programmieren, ansonsten macht das Ding noch irgendeinen
Scheiß, was wurde da drauf, ja, guck ich mir, guck ich mir an, ja wie gesagt mein Unify
Controller läuft auch auf dem Raspberry Pi und ich muss euch mal sagen, ich habe mir
im Keller jetzt noch einen UAP Lite, wie auch immer der genau heißt, eingebaut, so einen
hier, kein WiFi 6, ich brauche im Keller kein WiFi 6, dafür ist das Ding schön günstig,
gut schön günstig sind 60 Euro oder so, 70 Euro sogar und ich muss echt sagen, seitdem
ich mir das Ding hier noch im Keller eingebaut habe, das WLAN ist wirklich, das hätte ich
nie gedacht, was so ein Access Point ausmachen kann, ja Unify habe ich in meinem Home Assistant
drinne, als Device Tracker, hast du noch deinen alten PC mit Xeon CPU von 2013, ja, ja, hab
ich noch, allerdings nicht mehr hier stehen, sondern ich glaube auf dem Dachboden, aber
ich schmeiße die ja nicht weg, warum fragst du?
So, das hätte ich echt nicht gedacht, dass das so viel bringt, ne, also ich habe hier
im Erdgeschoss einen Access Point, einen UAP Pro habe ich im Erdgeschoss, hier oben habe
ich ein bisschen Nano HD und ich hatte immer Probleme, egal wie ich es positioniert habe,
der Empfang im Keller war prinzipiell scheiße, dann kam dazu, dass es im Flur auch nicht
toll war, ich habe teilweise schon Probleme, wenn ich aufs Klo gegangen bin, oben und ich
habe jetzt einfach noch im Keller einen zusätzlichen Access Point hingehängt, jetzt habe ich 3
Stück Keller, Erdgeschoss, 1. Stock, Dach ist nix, brauche ich auch nicht und wisst ihr
was?
Ich kann zwar nicht ganz nachvollziehen, warum sich manche Devices dahin verbinden,
beispielsweise die Lampe, so eine WiFi RGB Lampe drüben im Wohnzimmer, verbindet sich
im Keller zum Access Point, also eine Lampe im ersten Stock verbindet sich zum Access
Point im Keller, warum auch immer, alles andere kann ich ja nachvollziehen, aber die Lampe
meint, sie muss ins Keller, muss muss ins Keller, alles gleiche SSIDs, ja ja, ich habe
den AP AC Throne erreicht im ganzen Haus, ja, also du kriegst aber garantiert Probleme,
wenn du eingestellt hast, dass 5 WiFi 6, also 5 GHz Geräte gezwungen werden 5 GHz zu verwenden,
dann hast du bestimmt Empfangsprobleme, das würde ich nämlich immer ausschalten, ja ja,
du musst die Automat, genau das meine ich Asuro, die automatische Optimierung muss unbedingt
aus, das ist totaler Müll, automatische Optimierung macht ja so Sachen wie 5G Geräte, ich sage
schon 5G, stimmt ja nicht, WiFi 6 5 GHz Geräte müssten 5 GHz verwenden, das ist totaler
Fail, wenn ich aufs Klo gehe und nur 2,4 habe und das ganze bisschen langsamer ist, soll
mir auch recht sein, weil das ist einfach so, 2,4 GHz wedern geht einfach bedeutend besser
durch Wände und hat dementsprechend eine bessere Reichweite als 5 GHz, dafür ist 5 GHz schneller
und je nach Auslastung in der Region, hast du damit eh dann mehr Performance, hast du
für deine APs irgendein Steering damit sich absprechen, wer für welches Gerät ist oder
hast du einfach, ich habe auf allen Geräten die gleiche SSIDs, aber das UniFi Zeug macht
unter der Haube schon Access Point Roaming, also das ist relativ gut, also ich kann beispielsweise
irgendwie Musikstreams laufen haben oder Internetradio oder sonst was auf dem Handy und durchs Haus
laufen das bricht nicht ab, man kann das in den Settings auch ausstellen, ja Leistung
auf Mittel habe ich auch gemacht im Erdgeschoss, ich stelle jetzt aber auch nichts mehr dran
rum, weil es funktioniert alles ziemlich gut, ja also davon halte ich auch nichts, also für
Netzwerkgeräte an sich, außer Access Point, ich habe einen UniFi Edge Switch mit 10G,
die sind alles auch ganz gut, aber für alle anderen Sachen würde ich das auch nicht nehmen.
Da habe ich entweder meine MikroTik Kisten, die ja von der Bedienung her auch nicht alles
andere als Referenz sind, also gerade Bruter OS auf MikroTik ist ja wirklich schon absoluter
Wildwuchs, ich meine hier WebFick ist einfach, ich muss mir mal lachen, wenn ich das komische
Wort lese, ich meine es ist WebConfig, aber es ist WebFick, es gehört zu WebFig, aber
ich muss mir mal lachen, wenn ich das lese, das ist halt auch schon ziemlich, ich will
nicht quick, ich will WebFick, das ist halt auch schon ziemlich BigBrain, das ganze MikroTik
Ding, du hast hier 30 Milliarden Einstellungen, die du machen kannst, IPsec ist halt auch
mit allen möglichen Sachen und sonst wie, ihr habt es gesehen doppelten Tastendruck
hier wieder und damit bin ich aber privat ganz zufrieden, ich habe ja relativ viel MikroTik,
also ich habe eine Mischung bei mir daheim aus Unify Geräten als Access Point und als,
ich nenne es mal jetzt Core Switch, also halt mein 10 Gigabit Switch, wo dann alles andere
dran angeschlossen wird, nicht wirklich ein Core Switch, aber ihr wisst was ich meine,
mit feuchtem Atem in die Maus hauchen, wenn du eine Logitech hast, damit lässt sich Doppelklick
lösen, ja Doppelklick geht ja, aber manchmal macht er doppelt, soll ich mal da rein hauchen,
ok, so ob das jetzt was gebracht hat, habe ich so meine Zweifel, das glaube ich nicht,
so also zumindest, mein Netzwerk besteht so aus einer Mischung aus Ubiquity, also die
Access Points und meinem Edge, 10 Gigabyte Edge Switch und der Rest ist eigentlich MikroTik,
also der Router ist MikroTik, Switch im Wohnzimmer ist MikroTik, Switch im Erdgeschoss ist MikroTik,
Switch im Keller ist MikroTik, ja gut, dann habe ich noch eine Fritzbox für VoIP, bleibt
da nichts anderes übrig, VoIP willst du nicht selber machen, da glaube ich, gibt es Leute
die so massu schiesslich sind und daheim VoIP bzw. irgendwelche IP Telefonie selbst machen
und nicht was fertiges nehmen, also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, VoIP ist eines der painst
champigsten IT Themen, die ich kenne, ist die VoIP Fritzbox als Client im Netzwerk,
ne die ist gar nicht im WLAN, die ist bei Kabel angeschlossen, also bei mir sieht das
so aus, machen wir mal wieder Huge Massive Pain Skills, also bei mir sieht das so aus,
als nächster ist die Unity Media, dieses Drecks Teil, Connectbox, so, dann ist direkt
daran angeschlossen, eine Fritzbox von AVM, wo manche Leute behaupten es wäre die rote
Pest aus Berlin, aber das ist eine Fritzbox, so die ist direkt daran angeschlossen, an
die Unity Media Connectbox, dann haben wir hier einen Mikrotik Router, ich mal mal wie
das angeschlossen ist, und da ist dann mein 10G Switch dran, machen wir mal ein bisschen
größer, 10G Switch, so, und dann haben wir, dann haben wir, dann haben wir, dann haben
wir, Access Points, AP, und das ganze quasi dann dreimal, stimmt nicht ganz, stimmt nicht
ganz, da ist noch ein Switch dazwischen, weil da unten noch der Raspberry Pi dran ist, so,
so sieht das bei mir ungefähr aus, netzwerktechnisch, jetzt ohne Geräte und ohne sinnlose Zwischendinger,
ja, so sieht das aus, so, und hier ist das ganze interne Zeug dran, ja, gut, was gibt
es da groß zu zeigen, ich meine in Wirklichkeit ist es so, dass hier im Erdgeschoss, ah das
ist doof, hier im Erdgeschoss, ne das kann man so nicht malen, hier ist eigentlich noch
ein Switch dabei, und hier im Erdgeschoss hängt dann zum Beispiel noch ein Raspberry
Pi dran, für Unify Controller und meine Überwachungskameras, der ist da dran, der ist ganz praktisch, weil
der hängt quasi am gleichen Switch, das Dinge so konfiguriert, WLAN technisch, dass der
halt im gleichen physischen Layer 2 Ding hängt wie die Axis Points, das heißt der kann die
da drüber steuern, ja, genau, und Axis Points haben WLAN 1 default und WLAN 1337 für IoT,
also die machen 2 WLANs, die machen quasi einmal, einmal quasi, nennen wir es mal irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, ja, client WLAN, und dann machen die nochmal hier, man machs mal, machs mal
orange, so und dann machen die noch ein IoT WLAN, ich speichere mir das mal, das können
wir bestimmt gebrauchen, ja so ist das, so ist das bei mir daheim aufgebaut, na und hier
ist dann zum Beispiel auch der Internet Server mit Time Automatisierung drauf, und hier ist
auch mein Rechner drauf, das hier ist auch das Nass, das ist ja die gleiche Kiste, die
Gigabits mäßig dran, ja, ja und VoIP geht halt hier drüber, das hängt halt direkt außen
dran, da ist halt, braucht ja auch hier gar nicht dahinter zu sein, was haben die Portallöcher
jetzt dazu, was, hä, so und, ja hier hängen da noch solche Sachen dran, wie, ah hier gibt
es, ups, hier gibt es da noch so Sachen wie deckt, deckt, Telefone und sowas, Jane doch
nicht rumspammen, so, so sieht das bei mir daheim aus, exellent, gut, also wo sind wir
denn stehen geblieben, wow danke für den Sub, skalieren mit dem Unify Controller, klar
aber bei mir skaliert alles, diagonal 4D, ich mein sogar Lull ist dreidimensional, skaliert
schon, krass eigentlich, dass Leute noch Festnetz Telefone nutzen, na ja, warum nicht, ich mein,
ich hab ne App bei mir auf dem Handy von meinem VoIP Anbieter, dass das Handy auch klingelt,
das ist lustig, da kann man unterwegs dran gehen, aber daheim, ich hab ja nicht unbedingt
immer das Handy am Start, na also ich hab, ich hab zwei Fritz Phones dran, also wirklich
so ein oldschool analog, nein ist ja nicht analog, ist halt deckt Zeug, ich hab zwei
Fritz Phones dran und ne VoIP App auf dem Handy, ja hier drüber geht unter anderem auch die
Tür klingelt dann, dann hast du deine ganze Anrufliste wieder auf mehreren Geräten verteilt,
ja, gut alles was über die Rufnummer reinkommt, ist kein Problem, aber ja klar hab ich, aber
das stört mich nicht, großartig, naja, mal ne Frage an die Haltnasen, ich bin letztes
Jahr in die IT umgestiegen, von wo, was hast du vorher gemacht, schreib mal Ed Wupplos
dabei falls du noch da bist und antwortest, dass ich sehe, weil ich bin mit dem Chat ziemlich
hinten dran, ich bin letztes Jahr in der IT umgestiegen und hab mir einen kompletten
Java Script Stack angeeignet, jetzt bin ich bei einer Firma runtergekommen die voll auf
Java, ein Bylight, nein so schlimm ist das gar nicht und Angular Sets, kann das sein,
dass diese Full Stack JavaScript Application noch nicht so im Umlauf sind, hab das Gefühl
alles den Sets, naja, ich persönlich bin ja der Ansicht, Full Stack JavaScript gibt es
nur, aus dem Grund, weil Frontend Leute unbedingt auch Backend machen wollten, ansonsten, wenn
man mal ehrlich ist, hat Node.js keinen sittlichen Mehrwert, weißte, da regen sich jetzt ganz
viele Node.js Entwickler drüber auf und sagen Max das geht doch nicht, ich mein klar, nein
es stimmt so nicht, wie ich das gesagt hab, doch es hat schon einen gewissen Mehrwert,
du hast zum Beispiel den Vorteil, dass du, wenn man das, das ist in der Theorie so, ich
weiß nicht wie oft das wirklich in der Praxis vorkommt, du kannst schon deine Models zum
Beispiel sharen zwischen Frontend und Backend, das ist dann eventuell ganz, ganz nice, Node.js
hat den Vorteil, dass es relativ easy zu benutzen ist und der größte Vorteil von Node.js kommt
nicht unbedingt dadurch, dass es Node.js ist, sondern dadurch, dass NPM einfach für
nahezu alles irgendwelche Packages hat, also das große Ökosystem auf NPM ist tatsächlich
ein echter Pluspunkt, aber ansonsten muss man ehrlich sagen, is even, is odd, ja es
gibt totalen Schwachsinn, aber halt wenn du NPM installierst siehst du halt und installierst
es halt im Internet, aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, die Kombination aus Java und Angular
gut, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, Angular war wirklich nicht meine favorisierte Sache,
ich hab damit nie großartig was gemacht, ich hab da mal zu Angular 1 Zeiten was zugesehen,
das fand ich ganz cool, aber mittlerweile ist Angular, ich hab da auch keinen Bock drauf
mich damit mal zu beschäftigen, für mich als Außenstehender sieht Angular einfach
nach einem riesen Haufen bloated, das ist quasi so das Java der JavaScript Frameworks
mit Dependency Injection und Factories und Adapter Pattern und ach keine Ahnung was
es da nicht alles gibt, das ist halt ein riesen Ding, ja, also ich persönlich mag ja Kombination,
könnt ihr euch jetzt fast schon denken, ASP.NET Core und Vue.js, aber so richtige Fullstack
JavaScript Applikation, ich weiß gar nicht wieviel es davon wirklich live gibt, zum üben
und basteln ist Node immer gut, aber was fällt euch aus dem Kopf ein, wer hat, wer von den
großen Services ist komplett Node.js, also YouTube ist glaube ich irgendeine Mischung
aus Python und, nee nicht PAP, was ist YouTube C++ und Python oder so, nee Discord Electron
zählt nicht, mein Server Backend, dann hast du Twitter, die waren mal Ruby, Ruby on Rails,
aber ich glaube mittlerweile ist Twitter irgendwas JVM Java basiert das auch, ja, also so wirklich
Fullstack Javaske, mir fällt jetzt da nicht so viel ein ehrlich gesagt, das stimmt ganz
viele hippe Startups, aber das ist tatsächlich, das ist also die Kombination aus Java im Backend
und gut ob es jetzt Angular oder was anderes ist, Frontend ist so ziemlich weit verbreitende
Business Geschichte, wobei ich von der Java, von der Java Welt keine Ahnung habe, aber
ich sag mal so, ich kann es lesen, ich könnte auch was drin programmieren, aber muss nicht
unbedingt sein, ja was unsere Azubis aktuell machen wird mich wirklich mal interessieren,
lange nichts davon gehört, der eine hat mir letztens eine Azure Function eingerichtet,
hat er zwei Tage rumgeklickt, aber ansonsten habe ich lange nichts mehr von unseren Azubis
gehört, ja gut, da haben wir auf der Arbeit auch einen, bei dem weiß ich, der ist irgendwie
auch schon keine Ahnung, 150 Jahre verheiratet, da sagt er immer, dass ihn seine Frau nervt
und deswegen geht er auf die Arbeit, da war auch fast die gesamte Corona Zeit auf der Arbeit
in Frankfurt, aber ich habe ja auch keine Schmerzen damit, wenn die Leute hingehen,
dass sie daheim was stört, aber man sollte nicht den Leuten, die daheim bleiben wollen,
dann auch noch Steine in den Weg legen, Deko 50 Billar, danke schön für den Sub, äh
nicht Sub, für die Bits, das sind quasi, das ist ungefähr, das sind 5 Euro quasi,
was ein Sub auch kosten würde, der Scam Train steigt nicht, nein, der Scam Train ist immer
vor dem Chef im Betrieb, der Scam Train schläft nicht, der Scam Train ist immer vor dem Chef
im Betrieb und scammt die Subs schweißfrei, der Scam Train wird nie müde, genau, ey 50
Euro, ne, warte mal, ne, den kenne ich nicht, der fährt in die andere Richtung, ne, ja,
das ist eh lustig, ne, überall schieben sie immer noch Corona Panik, aber wenn die Bahn
streikt und da sich die Leute stapeln, das interessiert keinen, ja, das glaube ich auch,
das glaube ich auch, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Stonks Manager, dass die gar nicht
überrascht sind, dass die das einfach nur vorschieben mit wir sind überrascht, dass
die Leute denken so, oh vielleicht sollten wir das mal nicht so machen, aber ich glaube,
ich war einer der ersten, die offiziell diese Arbeitszeitänderung eingereicht haben bei
uns, sobald ich gehört habe, ich meine, wir haben das ja vorher schon oft gemacht mit Home
Office, aber sobald ich gehört habe, dass wir jetzt offiziell mit Arbeitszeitänderung
und so das machen können, ich war glaube ich, keine Ahnung, 2 Stunden nachdem das veröffentlicht
wurde, dass es das gibt, hatte ich das Ding ausgefüllt und meinem Chef geschickt.
Die Musik ist tatsächlich sogar relativ laut, aber die ist halt sehr gechillort, gechillsort.
Doch, danke für den Sub, 4 Monate, Max420, hey, ich bin der erste, also wenn jemand darüber
abstimmen würde oder so, ob Cannabis legalisiert werden soll, ich bin der erste, der sagen
würde, ja, ich selber, rauch nix, was gibt es da sonst noch, rauch nix, schnief nix,
trink nix, spritz nix, ich mach nichts davon, aber ich bin trotzdem für die Legalisierung.
Hüton, der Wein vom Italiener geht, ne, ihr kennt mich, ich trinke auch kaum was, also
was das angeht, habe ich einen äußerst gesunden Lebensstil, aber ich bin zu fett.
Ich kann aber nicht alles haben.
Der Cute Mod, ja, das frage ich mich auch, von dem habe ich schon lange nichts mehr gehört,
wo ist der Cute Mod, was hältst du von Fullstack Javascript App, Javascript, Beispiel, oh Gott,
die Abkürzung Javascript, ich muss kurz überlegen, was ist Maven, View, Angular, ach du Scheiße,
Javascript Stack Abkürzung, Note, Note, was ist denn, okay, was ist M und was ist E in
dem Fall, MongoDB könnte sein, für Datenbank, Ah, Express, ja, du hast Recht, ja, wegen
Express, MongoDB, Express, View und Note, oh, das gleiche hier mit Angular, okay, ja,
also es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass irgendwelche hippe Startups
das schon so machen, aber gerade bei uns so im Bankenumfeld, da wo ich arbeite, ist Java
das Ding, also Java Backend, sonst da führt kein Weg dran vorbei, der andere Seite mal
ganz ehrlich, ich sehe immer noch nicht den großen Vorteil von, ich habe ja gerade so
ein paar Sachen aufgezählt, aber ich sehe immer noch nicht den großen Vorteil von alles
Javascript, außer eben, dass wenn man halt Javascript gut kann und Frontend-Stells macht
und vielleicht ein bisschen Logik scheren will zwischen Frontend und Backend, dann kann
ich mir das, kann ich mir das vorteilhaft vorstellen, aber ansonsten, was spricht gegen, sagen wir,
C-Sharp, Java, PHP, was auch immer, Backend und man lässt Javascript im Frontend, da
wo es seine Stärken hat, spricht da überhaupt nichts dagegen, weil, wenn du jetzt, ob du
jetzt irgendeine API hast in Node oder in Java, macht doch eigentlich keinen Unterschied,
kannst auch Django machen oder so, Python, Python, Python, kannst du auch machen, Ruby
on Rails kannst du auch machen, Spring Boot, Kotlin, alles mögliche, Cobol, Rest API,
ich glaube es gibt keinen Webserver in Cobol, gibt es einen Cobol Webserver, warum, heute
programmieren wir eine Webseite mit Cobol, ja Moment, der verwendet auch einen fertigen
Webserver, der verwendet auch einen fertigen Webserver, jaja, die verwenden auch einen
fertigen Webserver, gibt es einen Cobol Webserver, was, Cobol on Wheelchair, Microweb Framework
for Cobol, Moment, Moment, warum gibt es sowas, ja gut, der Typ hat auch kein Bock,
das zu supporten, Cobol on Cocks, ja, die machen das, der Webserver, es hat keiner Bock
einen Webserver in Cobol zu programmieren, guck, die lassen die Webserver Geschichte
auch über Apache machen, keiner mag Cobol Webserver programmieren, ich weiß gar nicht,
kann man überhaupt Sockets gescheit ansprechen, über Cobol bestimmt, Crap, Alter, ok, komm
weiter, wollt ihr übrigens, das ist übrigens der Titel, ist ein bisschen Chebat, gebe ich
zu, ich habe ja gesagt, so viele Sachen einkaufen muss ich gar nicht, ich bin eigentlich nur
angekommen, dass ich ein bisschen mit euch schwätzen kann, aber ein paar Sachen muss
ich doch gleich noch einkaufen, aber ich gucke erstmal Chat durch, wir haben ja Zeit, kennst
du eine Möglichkeit, den Python Console Output in Tick, mit diesem TCL, nicht Web GUI Zeug,
hab ich nie großartig was gemacht, keine Ahnung, aber das eingebaute Python GUI ist
schon Paynes Champ, ich probiere Gehub mal aus später, will es jetzt hier nicht im Stream
installieren, sonst kackt es mir ab und mein Haus geht nicht mehr oder so was, kann man
in Gehub Makros machen, ich brauche Makros, das ist wichtig, ich brauche Makros, also
ordentliche Makros, am besten mit Lua, das war das beste an der Logitech Software, dass
man nur an Makros machen konnte, gucken wir uns gleich an, ich habe heute wieder bei Absolut
Basic Dinge gefailt, ich wollte mir ein neues Deo kaufen und ich habe das falsche gekauft,
aber die Benamungen sind ja auch richtig bescheuert, guckt euch das mal an, wie viele Sachen die
mit Pure im Namen haben, das sind 50 Seiten mit Pure, Pure Fresh, Pure Ocean, Pure sonst
was, Pure Nature, Pure Natural, Pure sonst was, ja ich habe es falsche gekauft, richtig
bei den Basic Dingen des täglichen Lebens gefailt wieder, alles bloated, ok wir gucken
uns jetzt das Video an mit der Insulinpumpe, nee ich muss den Chat vorher fertig machen,
lieber in Java und dann out of Memory, geht eigentlich, eigentlich sollte ja sowas wie
ein Garbage Collector in Java dafür sorgen, dass du weniger Memory Leaks produzierst, aber
auf der anderen Seite ist es überhaupt kein Problem in Java und C Sharp Memory Leaks zu
fabrizieren, selbst ohne Unsafe Code, also nichts einfacher als das als das Memory Leak
in C Sharp zu fabrizieren, schon cringe, kein WiFi 6 im Keller, ja ich weiß, weiß, richtig
richtig cringe, also ich glaube WiFi 6 beziehungsweise so 5-600 Mbit braucht man unbedingt im Keller,
das ist ganz wichtig, der ist gut, ja da habe ich auch im Erdgeschoss, ja pvz kann man immer
mal wieder neu installieren und dann durchspielen, das ist ja selbst mit allem was es so zu machen
gibt, relativ schnell durchgespielt, kannst ein paar Tage immer mal wieder spielen, dann
ist es durch, ja schon ein bisschen cringe, ich weiß, ja alles gleiche SSID, ja das muss
man unbedingt machen im Unify Controller, ich zeige euch mal wie das aussieht, da gibt
es so, gibt es so ein Bild, ja zeig mal, ja super, super geile Auflösung, ah yes, erkennt
ihr alles, ich finde das ist schon ziemlich gut, sag mal warum ist denn die Quali so kacke,
es gibt hier genau, es gibt hier irgendwo ein Dings, ne nicht Advanced Features, es gibt
hier irgendwo sowas Auto Optimize Network und das müsst ihr unbedingt ausschalten, ja,
wo auch immer das jetzt ist, da hier, das da ist es, das muss man ausschalten oder wenn
man keine Probleme hat, kann man das natürlich auch angeschaltet lassen, das ist jetzt keine
Pflicht, aber das Ding hat einen Nachteil wenn das angeschaltet ist und zwar wenn das
Unify Zeug gemerkt hat, dass euer Gerät, sag mal mal euer Smartphone oder so, 5 Gigahertz
SP ich es, dann zwingt es das Gerät sich mit 5 Gigahertz zu verbinden und 5 Gigahertz
geht halt oftmals nicht so weit wie 2,4 Gigahertz WLAN, dementsprechend kann es durchaus sein,
dass der Access Point nicht weit weg ist und ihr auf dem Klo trotzdem keinen richtigen
Empfang habt, eigentlich schon richtig cringe, was ist denn OpenNet Admin, das kenne ich
nicht, aber was hat das denn mit DNS, DHCP Integration zu tun, du kannst damit doch nicht
deine Unify Geräte einstellen oder, ONA, das ist ein IP Adress Management oder, Online
Demo, sieht aus wie 1995, ja es sieht wirklich aus wie 1995, oh Leute ist das, ist das Dings,
wie heißt dieses JavaScript Framework, was auch TV Headend und sonst was, nicht Express,
so ein ganz altes, so ein ganz ganz altes Java, das sieht aus wie, ich hab vergessen
wie das heißt, XJS, XJS, genau, so sieht das aus, wo ich mich immer gefragt hab, warum
um alles in der Welt benutzt man sowas, ja XJS, XJS ist wirklich richtig a pain in the
ass, alter, guck mal den Kram, den will schon gar keiner mehr verwenden, ZIP Calling ist
cringe, ja alles, alles ist cringe, alles was man selbst nicht gut findet ist prinzipiell
erstmal cringe, das war ja nur, Moment mal, in diesem Clip, das war ja nur dazu da, um
zu demonstrieren, dass, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was wollte ich denn da nochmal da, irgendwas
wo ich gesagt hab, man muss sich selbst schlagen, niemals VoIP selber, ja seh ich auch so, oh
nice, will sie überhaupt Festnetz telefonen, tja, richtig Boomer, was soll ich sagen, bin
alt genug, cac.box gibt's das wirklich, mach ich jetzt aber nicht auf, cacw.services gibt's,
beste Domain die ihr euch merken müsst, aktuell hab ich den Server runtergefahren, aber hier,
cacw.services, jemand zufällig die Idee für einen Router, der nicht die Welt kostet, aber
ein bisschen mehr Routing Kapazität hat, als das Unify, Dings, Blah Gateway, der x-beliebige
Mikrotik Router für 50 Euro, aber Video Streams darüber laufen lassen, Müss muss auch funktionieren,
kann nicht sein, dass bei einem einzelnen User mit 1-2 Streams das Ding irgendwie Probleme
macht, das muss anderes, das muss andere Probleme haben, das muss an was anderem liegen.
Die Connectbox ist von Unity Media oder Vodafone jetzt, aber zu Unity Media Zeiten war die Connectbox
so ein Hybridgerät aus Modem, mit ein bisschen WLAN und mit ein bisschen Switch und mit ein
bisschen Telefon, also quasi die Fritzbox von Unity Media sozusagen, hab ich aber alles
ausgeschaltet.
Ja, muss ich mal gucken, gerade was Heimautomatisierung angeht, hab ich das schon lange vor da mal
eine Tour zu machen, aber ich muss gucken, dass ich nicht wupp wupp leake zu viel, da
hätt ich viel zu tun, bis ich da alle Clients eingemalt hab, also das merke ich, wenn ich
durch meinen DHCP scrolle und es haben nicht mal alle dynamische IPs, da bin ich gut beschäftigt.
Die Connectbox hat glaube ich sogar 4 Netzwerkanschlüsse, vielleicht sogar 5.
Wo geht das Internet rein, na hier, hier kommt, hier kommt das Kabel aus dem Keller, wie gesagt
ich hab Raspberry Pi, Raspberry Pi mit Unify Controller, DN Punt, Dankeschön für den
Sub Overlay hier, huge ihr beiden, neun Monate sogar schon, Massive Subscription hier, welches
wieder am 10G Switch, boah muss ich jetzt nachgucken, ja ich hab mich da drüber schon
ausgelassen, ich find's scheiße, wohlgemerkt nicht, dass die das Recht haben zu streiken
sondern die Auswirkungen find ich scheiße und mir ist es egal, ob es an der Bahn oder
an der GDL liegt, ich will einfach nur fahren und pünktlich ankommen.
Unify Controller in Kubernetes, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt gescheit funktioniert,
aber dann können wir hyperscalen diagonal, wenn der in Kubernetes ist, achtdimensional,
dann schon, ja das hab ich auch schon gesehen, es gibt, ich hab gesehen, es gibt für, also
für den ESP32, es gibt MicroPython, es gibt eine Lua Geschichte, es gibt die übliche
standardmäßige C, C++ Geschichte und ich glaube es gibt auch mittlerweile die Möglichkeit
Javascript auszuführen, warum auch immer man das machen will, aber das geht, du hast
mit Bode im Back, was ist Bode, gibt es nicht, Bode gibt es nicht, ja in dem Fall wirklich
lieber C++, ach no, ich hab mit Bode, alter, he lacks critical information, also nix, aber
dass es standardmäßig Javascript frontend am Start ist, ist schon ein bisschen übertrieben,
Angular übertreibt es halt komplett, tatsächlich, ich glaube dafür ist es wirklich gut, aber
die meisten, die damit anfangen, also wenn das businessmäßig benutzt wird, die machen
damit bestimmt auch kleine Sachen, einfach so nach dem Motto, es gibt ja, es gibt ja,
das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau, ja, das habe ich jetzt schon öfters gehört, dass
manche Unternehmen, gerade jetzt nicht so supergroße, sondern durchaus auch kleinere, dass sie
total festgefahren sind auf so eine gewisse Technik, die sagen dann, wir machen nur.NET
oder keine Ahnung, oder wir machen nur Angular, warum, ich verstehe das immer nicht, warum
legt man sich schon im Voraus auf irgendwas fest und sagt, dass man prinzipiell alles
damit macht, ich meine, ok, wenn man die Leute und die Programmierer hat, die sich damit
am besten auskennen, ich mache auch die meisten Sachen in C-Sharp, weil es mir meine Lieblingssprache
ist, aber wenn sich was anderes anbietet, weil es eben die Vorteile überwiegt von einer
anderen Technologie, ja, dann sehe ich da kein Problem drin, dass mit was anderem, zumal
ich habe schon Sachen in Go gemacht, sogar in C, in JavaScript, in Ruby, in Python, alles
mögliche schon, warum auch nicht?
Ja, kann man sich darüber streiten, ich glaube, das ist alles durchaus in Ordnung, was es
an Frontend gibt, und ich muss sagen, ich finde es ja ganz gut mittlerweile, was JavaScript
angeht, dass sich View, React und Angular durchgesetzt haben, es entsteht zwar immer
noch täglich 50 neue JavaScript-Frameworks, aber die großen drei sind über die letzten
Jahre doch relativ beständig, was gibt es denn so Neues an JavaScript-Frameworks, was
richtig, auch mal Svelte gibt es vielleicht noch, aber was auch mal so richtig User anzieht,
du hast View, Angular, React, Deno ist kein Frontend-Framework, Deno ist Node-Abklatsch,
Svelte ist vielleicht noch so ein bisschen so ein Ding, aber ansonsten, die großen drei
und gut ist, das finde ich gut, das hat mal ein bisschen Stabilität in dieses JavaScript-Ökosystem
gebracht, wo ja sonst jeden Tag jeder was anderes gebaut hat und keine Woche mal was
Gleiches verwendet wurde, ja gibt es ja nicht mehr jetzt in dem Umfang, was heute gekauft
wird, gleich, gleich, Single-Side, ne, was ist SSR, immer die ganzen Abkürzungen, Single
Responsibility oder was soll das sein, Ach Server-Side Rendering, ja ok, das verstehe
ich, das verstehe ich, ja das lasse ich mir gefallen, ja Server-Side Rendering, das verstehe
ich, ja Bing-Picture-of-the-Day ist wichtig heute, was ist denn Bing-Picture-of-the-Day,
Bing-Picture-of-the-Day, Image of the Day, ein Kegel, sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Todesberg
aus Zelda, ein Vulkan, we finish to go backend plus Ruby on Rails frontend, was, das ergibt
keinen Sinn, das sind beides backend Geschichten, wie soll das funktionieren, hast gesehen Microsoft
Asher hatte Sicherheitslücken beim DB Service, jeder konnte RW drauf zugreifen, ja habe
ich gelesen, ich habe sie aber nicht genauer angeguckt, aber tja, Datenbank-Stellz, Kosmos-DB-Stellz,
war es glaube ich, kann schon mal passieren, ja, auf welche Fettnäpfchen sollte man beim
ersten Arbeitstag, da habe ich ein Video zu, guck mal, vielleicht hast du das auch schon
gesehen, ich weiß nicht, hier schau mal da, Tipps für den ersten Arbeitstag, wenn nicht,
kannst du es mal angucken, ich habe deine Nachricht überlesen, oh ich glaube nicht,
ich war einfach nur langsam, ich glaube mittlerweile habe ich was zu gesagt oder, der Sebaro lebt,
bewegt mich ziemlich, dass der Sebaro noch lebt, äh nein, ich weiß was es ist und so
grob wofür es da ist, aber damit habe ich noch gar nichts gemacht, ich bin wieder begeistert
was es alles gibt, ja, ist echt so, gerade, wie gesagt, gerade hier im Big Stonks Banken-Umfeld,
es ist saumäßig viel Java, kenn es ja von uns, warum wird heute alles über HTTP gemacht,
von Sauerei oder, was ist aus den guten alten Sachen geworden, warum überhaupt TCP, das
ist alles so wahnsinnig bloated, ich bin wieder für IPX und NetBOI und sowas, die guten alten
Klassiker sollten wir mal wieder rausholen, HTTP bloated Shit da, FDP genau, die Leute
wissen heute überhaupt nicht mehr was FDP ist, ich denke das hat was mit Melinda zu tun
oder so, nee, FDP oder WebDAF oder so, schau mal das von Notschritt, ja, das ist ein Notizprogramm
für Mac, ja, ich glaube wir haben hier einige Leute, die sweetpiesen auskennen, Jithub,
kannst du als Gist, als Gist hochladen auf Jithub und posten, da haben wir bestimmt
ein paar Leute, die sich damit auskennen, für Nicht-Programmierer, was ist dein Memory
Leak, wenn du Speicher belegst und den nicht mehr freigibst und das nächste Mal wieder
Speicher belegst und den nicht mehr freigibst, wenn du vergisst Speicher freizugeben, möglichst
an Stellen wo du das auch noch öfters machst, dann benutzt dein Programm immer mehr RAM
und gib dir nie frei und irgendwann hast du ein kleines Furzprogramm, was 3GB verbraucht
und irgendwann crasht und die besten Memory Leaks macht man immer noch mit C++, ah, das
ist eine gute Frage, was ist so ein gutes Programmiersprachen Portfolio nach dem Studio,
also als erstes finde ich wichtig, dass man eine Sprache wirklich gut kann, das macht
vieles einfacher, gerade auch das Lernen weiterer Sprachen, aber man braucht so eine
0815 Standard Sprache, immer wenn man was machen will, dass man einfach sich weniger
mit der Sprache beschäftigen muss, wird heute noch geschoppt, ja ja ein paar Sachen kaufen
wir noch ein, wie gesagt, ich sag ihr, der Titel ist heute ein bisschen gebait gewesen,
ich hab einige Sachen, aber hält sich in Grenzen, ich hab den Stream heute angemacht,
dass wir ein bisschen schwätzen können, kennst dich von YouTube, ja nice, dass du den Weg
her gefunden hast, du hast dir leider heute einen relativ langweiligen Stream ausgesucht,
also es ist wichtig, dass man eine Sprache wirklich gut kann, weil wenn irgendjemand
mal zu dir kommt und fragst, kannst du xy machen, dann musst du dich nicht groß um
die Sprache kümmern, sondern so sagst, ja mach ich, machst deine Standard IDE auf,
redet vor was auch immer und bastelst in deiner Standard Sprache los, erstmal gar nicht so
wichtig, was das ist, wichtig ist, dass du eine Sprache wirklich flüssig kannst, auch
die Standard Library dazu, dass du einfach Probleme relativ schnell lösen kannst, so
und das bringt dir natürlich auch was, wenn du weitere Sprachen lernen willst, aber kommen
wir mal zu dem Punkt, also wenn es ins Cloud Umfeld geht, dann ist auf jeden Fall Go angesagt,
Go, Python, so diese Kombination ist, gerade Github Projekte gehen ja da durch die Decke,
allerdings würde ich dir trotzdem noch eine ordentliche Backend Sprache mit der nötigen
Performance empfehlen plus Javascript, Go, Python, Javascript und dann suchst du dir
aus C Sharp, Java, irgendwas, das ist eine gute Mischung, Javascript Frontend brauchst
du, am Frontend kommst du eigentlich nicht vorbei, also Javascript ist Pflicht mittlerweile,
wie gesagt das muss nicht deine beste Sprache sein, aber du sollst ein bisschen durchblicken,
mit Go, Python und dann irgendwie x-beliebische andere Backendsprache noch, irgendwas, was
du auch mal Performance mäßig verwenden kannst, wie gesagt es ist egal, ob C Sharp
ist, Java, kannst auch Go im Backend verwenden, ja, aber also Python, Go, Javascript ist
wunderbar, ich würde halt noch irgendwas klassisches Objektorientiertes noch ein bisschen dazu
empfehlen, Java ist sicherlich die Business Variante.
Was macht Go so gut fürs Backend, Go hat ein paar große Vorteile was Cloud angeht, dadurch
dass du Self Contained Executables hast, die auch nicht so wahnsinnig groß sind, so ein
Go Programm fällt raus als ausführbare Datei mit allem was dabei ist, keine Frameworks
mehr installieren und nix, das ist so eines der Sachen die und rückwärts kompatibel
lauffähig bis Linux Kernel 2.6.32 oder so, also das ist gerade für, ähm, wir skalieren
Container rauf und runter und schieben neue Versionen hin, das macht halt Go richtig gut,
so und was die Sprache an sich auszeichnet, du kannst dir übrigens mal ein Video dazu
angucken, ich hab ja ein Video zur Einsteigerprogrammiersprache gemacht, aber sie hat ja
so das Aushängeschild von Go, ist ja die ganze, ich weiß ich sollte es nicht Multithreading
nennen, weil das ist es ja nicht, es sind ja Go Routines, das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig
Asynchron oder ein eigener Thread sein, aber ich sag das jetzt mal trotzdem, du kannst
in Go relativ gut asynchrone Sachen machen, ohne dass es blockt und auch Interthread Kommunikation
und so ist, in Go relativ gut, dazu kommt, dass Go noch eine halbwegs umfangreiche Standard
Library hat und was halt auch mittlerweile in Go richtig gut ist, dass du einen ziemlich
großen Library Pool auf GitHub hast, für alles mögliche.
Ich persönlich mag Go nicht so sehr, ich hab schon Sachen in Go gemacht, aber ich werd
mit der Syntax einfach nicht so hundertprozentig warm.
Es gibt dann so ein paar Sachen bei Go, also das verstehe ich nicht, einmal, dass sie dich
compilertechnisch so gängeln, so nach dem Motto Unused Imports, Compiler Fehler, warum
sind Unused Imports Compiler Fehler, es sollte zumindest einen Flag geben, dass man das ausschalten
kann oder Unused Variables Compiler Fehler, du willst erstmal was auskommentieren und
testen, ob es daran lag, nein kannst du nicht, weil du noch 50 andere Sachen auch auskommentieren
musst.
Das find ich nervig bei Go, es wäre ja vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn man sagt, hey ich mach ein
Release Build, dann will ich das nicht haben, aber das ist nervig, ne ja, Visual Studio
Coach schmeißt vielleicht die Imports automatisch raus, aber nicht Unused Variables, es ist
auf jeden Fall nervig.
So und dann, was ich in Go auch nicht so schön finde, ist, dass die an manchen Stellen sehr
minimalistisch sind, so nach dem Motto, warum soll ich einen Array mit Filter und Select
haben, wenn ich doch Vorschleifen machen kann, ist also die Go Philosophie, Go hat mal ganz
gerne 3 Nested For Loops, weil es nichts anderes gibt, Generics gibt es auch irgendwann in
50 Jahren mal, ja also ich werd mit Go nicht abschließend warm, was das angeht, es ist
aber sicherlich eine Sprache, die aktuell sehr viel Anklang findet.
Ja, allerdings, das mag schon sein, dass die dann drin bleiben, deswegen könnte man ja
sagen, hey wenn ich ein Release Build mache, dann ist das Pflicht, aber wenn ich am entwickeln
bin, das ist einfach für einen schnellen Ausprobier Workflow hinderlich, wenn du immer die Hälfte
deines Programms und an unterschiedlichen Stellen auskommentieren willst, wenn du nur
eine Sache rausschmeißen willst, also mich nervt das, es gab ja sogar schon mal ein Go
Compiler Fork deswegen, ansonsten Go ist aber angesagt, also wie gesagt, Go, Python, Javascript
ist eine super Kombination, ich würde halt noch so ein bisschen was alles klassisches
Objekt orientieren empfehlen, einfach so für eine Sprache, die erprobt ist und dafür gedacht
ist, möglichst schnell und ohne Schnick Schnack Probleme zu lösen, sowas wie C Sharp oder
Java.
So, ich hatte auch mal versucht bei mir ein IPAM daheim zu installieren, aber ich war
dazu faul für, mein IPAM ist mein DHCP Server, das muss reichen, IPAM ist IP Address Management,
falls sich das einer fragt.
Irko und Dankeschön, 24 Monate Hypersubscription, bietet sich C++ als Main Sprache an, C++ bietet
sich nie für irgendetwas an, C Sharp Backend und WPF, genau, genau, genau, so, ja, jetzt
jetzt kommen wir der Sache langsam näher, was hältst du von Mutation Testing, ich weiß
gar nicht, was das sein soll, ich finde es cool, wie breit hier die Skills seiner Community
gefächert sind, ja das stimmt, wir haben hier richtig viele Massive Brain Leute, exzellent,
im Chat habt ihr das gesehen, ihr wurdet gelobt, er meint euch, sogar der Chandler ist gemeint,
ja, ich finde auch das Frontend generell richtig cringe ist, es könnte einfach alles ein Kommando
Zeilen Tool sein, doch, doch, Go ist relativ populär, also ich würde sagen Javascript
und Python Go dürften so die populärsten Sprachen auf GitHub, auf Shithub sein, nee,
das ist gut, ASP.NET Core finde ich ist mit das beste Web Framework, was es gibt, wenn
du mich fragst, ist das besser als Go, exzellent, programmierst du öfters objektorientierend
ja so ein bisschen halt, so an denen jetzt nicht so religiös, dass ich sage hier, das
muss alles hier mit Factories, Abstracts und Override und was auch immer sein, wenn es
hin macht halt, und das finde ich übrigens auch die richtig coole Sache, was Microsoft
mit C Sharp macht, die haben sich, die sind zwar quasi mal als Microsoft Javas Clone gestartet,
aber die haben Java schon lange hinter sich gelassen, die hatten ja Generics quasi 100
Jahre vor Java, ordentliche, böse Zungen behaupten, Java hat bis heute keine richtigen,
die sind sich aber auch nicht so fein, das ganze objektorientiert ein bisschen eben liegen
zu lassen und C Sharp ist die letzten Versionen deutlich funktioneller geworden, von Pattern
Matching bis Record Types, Immutable Geschichten und so, also das finde ich wirklich gut bei
Microsoft.
Der, also früher, also C Sharp wurde ja von Anders Halsberg erfunden, das ist der Typ,
der auch TypeScript erfunden hat, also auf Auftrag von Microsoft hin, der Typ ist nicht
einfach nur Big Brain und sagt, ich erfinde jetzt mal zwei der beliebtesten Programmiersprachen,
das hat er schon auf Auftrag gemacht, vorher hat er glaube ich irgendwas mit Pascal, Delphi,
Delphi hat er glaube ich vorher gemacht, ja, also der war richtig Big Brain und vorausschauend,
was er mit C Sharp gemacht hat und der aktuelle Lead Designer von C Sharp, der heißt glaube
ich, jetzt hat es halt irgendein schwedischer Name, Matt Torxen oder so, der ist auch ziemlich
Big Brain, was neue Features angeht, Torxon, ne, Torgason, Torgason oder so heißt er glaube
ich, ja, du wurdest geforst auf C++, oh Pains Jam, Moment, ich muss mal gucken, wie der Typ
heißt, ich hab den Namen jetzt so falsch ausgesprochen, C Sharp Lead Designer, nein nicht anders der
Nachfolger von Anders Halsberg, hier den meine ich, Matt Torgason, ok, ja, ok, fast richtig,
das macht nichts, was sagt ihr zu Blazor Server Side, ganz ehrlich, ich bin ja großer
Fan was Microsoft mit der.NET Entwicklung macht, aber Blazor, im Ernst, also ich verstehe
weder den Sinn von Blazor Server Side noch den Sinn von Server, von Blazor Client Side,
das leuchtet mir einfach nicht ein, kannst du nur zwei negative C++, oh das wird schwierig,
ne, ne, wenn ich damit anfange ist es vorbei, was sind Record Types, oh kann ich das jetzt
kurz erklären, das sind Klassen in C Sharp, die standardmäßig immutable sind, also du
kannst sie nicht mehr ändern nachdem du sie angelegt hast, was für Multithreading und
Performance technisch teilweise ganz gut ist, weil wenn du dir sicher sein kannst, dass
eine Klasse sich nie wieder ändern kann nachdem du sie angelegt hast, du kannst Multithreaded
dich komplett auslassen, weil ihr könnt euch eine ganz einfache Regel merken, Multithreading
ist in 90% der Fällen kein Problem, oder in 99% der Fällen kein Problem, solange ihr
nicht parallel schreibt, parallel lesen, kein Problem, parallel lesen und einer schreibt
meistens auch kein Problem, aber sobald an zwei verschiedenen Stellen parallel geschrieben
wird, procken, in der Regel ist Multithreading kein Problem, wenn ihr einfach nur mehrere
Threads lesen, mehrere Threads lesen und ein Thread schreibt, in der Regel, du kannst je
nachdem was du machst, du kannst doofe Race Conditions haben, so nach dem Motto, ich schreibe
jetzt was rein und das ist halt nicht Atomic und dann lese ich was zur Hälfte aus oder
das alte noch oder, ja aber in der Regel ist das in Ordnung, ja 70€ ist teuer, ich
hab ja auch eins, aber das war auf jeden Fall billiger, 70€ hat ich dafür nicht ausgegeben,
Leute, ich hab den Chat gepackt, easy, so jetzt können wir noch was einkaufen, Poggers, nice,
ich hab's geschafft, ok, ich brauch was sehr unspektakuläres, Leute, ich brauch eine USB,
eine USB Verlängerung, 2 Meter, sowas hier, bam, 2x2 Meter, Basket, zack, hab ich eigentlich
mittlerweile schon alles immer noch, ja, hab ich noch nicht gekauft, ja, das kann ich mal
rausschmeißen, zur Cosmos DB Lücke hab ich noch nichts gesagt, weil ich es nur mitbekommen
habe, mich nicht näher damit jetzt beschäftigt habe, ich hab's mitbekommen, ich weiß, dass
man darauf zugreifen konnte auf die Datenbank von anderen Leuten, Read-Write anscheinend,
aber mehr auch nicht, ok, das brauch ich, hab ich euch eigentlich erzählt, meine Hausnummer,
meine RGB Hausnummer ist fast da, guck mal hier, ich hatte, Moment, ich muss mal kurz
das raussuchen, ich hatte mir 2 Hausnummern bestellt, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht,
ob ich die ans Haus dran mache, ich hab die bestellt, dass wir im Stream was zu basteln
haben, guck mal hier, RGB Hausnummern und das ganze sieht dann so aus, wenn's fertig
ist, ist das nicht Poggers, ist das nicht die nicest Hausnummer überhaupt, also ich finde,
das hat schon echt was, oder, wer hat so eine coole Hausnummer, brauch ich unbedingt,
ich frag mich nur, ob man im Dunkeln überhaupt die Nummer erkennt, hast du eigentlich an
diesem Anspiel-Event für Battlefield 2042 teilgenommen, es gibt noch kein Anspiel-Event,
es wird, vielleicht gab's schon eins, aber es wird noch eins geben und da bin ich auch
dabei, ja, das war übrigens lustig, die haben mich angeschrieben und haben mich nach meinen
Hardware-Specs, das hab ich glaube ich letztes Mal schon erzählt, nach meinen Hardware-Specs
gefragt, haben gesagt, ja, 8700k, 1080ti, 32G RAM, 2TB SSD, Platzfrei, überhaupt gar
kein Problem her damit und da meinten sie, da krieg ich auf einmal eine Mail als Antwort
so nach dem Motto, Max, wir schicken dir einen Leih-PC zum Anspielen zu, da hab ich gesagt,
hä, was, warum, Mindestanforderung ist eine RTX 2060, da musste ich dann erstmal sagen,
Moment, Moment, meine 1080ti ist 50% schneller als eine 2060, ihr braucht mir kein Recht
dazu zu schicken, das hat nichts mit NDA zu tun, Battlefield 2042, ja, wie gesagt, meine
Hausnummern sind auf dem Weg, wisst ihr was ich auch lustig finde, ich hab hier mal so
ein Video gemacht, China, China, China, wie hieß das, irgendwas mit China, technisch
heißt es Chinakram, hab ich mir so ein Video gemacht und dieses Video hat 380 Tage nach
Veröffentlichung auf einmal innerhalb von einem Monat 10.000 Views bekommen, ich hab
keine Ahnung warum, YouTube-Algorithmus hat sich gedacht, bam, jetzt, jetzt das ist das,
was die Leute sehen wollen, nein, nein, nein, nein, das wird schon funktionieren, ich hab
fast von löten getweetet, ja, ja, ja, hab ich, übrigens, hat davon eine Ahnung von
euch, ihr schaut mal, ich hab mir heute überlegt, ob ich mir nicht Photovoltaik aufs Dach machen
soll, ich bin da schon lange am überlegen, aber ich hab heute mal in so einem, im hessischen
Sonnenatlas, oder wie das heißt, geguckt, wie mein Dach liegt und mein Dach liegt tatsächlich
relativ gut, und ich hab das jetzt mal ausgerechnet, dass, wenn ich mir da ne Anlage draufbauen
würde, mit nem Akku, dass ich 50% meines Jahresbedarfs decken könnte, und je nach
dem durchaus auch mehr möglich, wenn ich ne größeren Akku nehme, ich würd mich aber
halt gerne mal vor Ort beraten lassen, hat da irgendjemand eine Ahnung, wo es da gute
Stellen gibt, also ich hab gesehen, bei der Verbraucherzentrale gibt es was für 30 Euro,
da kommt dann irgendeine Energie-Experte, keine Ahnung, wie expertisch der ist, aber
wahrscheinlich unabhängiger auf jeden Fall als von irgendeinem Anbieter, hat da jemand
Erfahrung mit, hat sich jemand mal was Solarsachen angeht beraten lassen, naja natürlich darf
ich das selber benutzen, selbstverständlich darf, das ist, das stimmt nicht, also du kannst
dir aufs Dach, also da gibt es ja verschiedene Modelle, du kannst entweder alles für dich
selbst benutzen und gar nichts einspeisen, aber das ist natürlich nicht so sinnvoll,
wenn du gar nichts einspeist, weil wenn du mehr produzierst, als du verbrauchen kannst,
da kriegst du wenigstens noch ein bisschen Geld für, aber du kannst das natürlich selbst
benutzen, und so richtig lohnen tut sich das auch an, erst wenn du viel selbst benutzt,
weil die Einspeiseförderergelder, die es gibt, werden immer weniger, und ich geh davon aus,
dass nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl, auch wenn die Grünen am Start sein werden vielleicht,
das nicht Bestand haben wird, zumindest nicht in der Höhe, ja wie gesagt, laut diesem Rechner
kann ich mindestens 50% decken, mindestens 2 Kilowattstunden Batterie, Akku, Kilowattstunden
ist ja die Menge, ich kenne bloß Ampere Stunden für Akkus und auch nicht überall hin, das
heißt, wenn ich das ein bisschen größer baue und vielleicht noch einen größeren Akku nehme,
dann könnte ich vielleicht sogar 60% oder so decken, das wäre auf jeden Fall schonmal
cool, weil Stromkosten wären auch nicht billiger, ok, hat auch keiner von euch die Ahnung, na
dann muss ich mal gucken, so wo wir gerade bei AliExpress sind, ich will mir noch eine
Lampe bauen und das heißt, ich brauche unbedingt mal wieder einen 16x16 LED Matrix, das ist
das erste schon, was du als Dings kriegst, 16x16 LED Matrix, ah die sind günstiger geworden,
wir sind jetzt wieder runter auf 11 Euro, die wollten da mal 26 Euro teilweise für,
ok Quaid, ja 11 Euro ist in Ordnung, 11 Euro kann ich dafür bezahlen, alles brauche ich,
Versand, Standard Shipping, die China Chinesen, Alter, das ist auch Taktik oder, dass man
das auf keinen Fall macht, ein Akku lohnt sich sehr selten, meinste, ich meine allein
schon dadurch, dass du im Sommer oder generell auch zu anderen Zeiten was verbrauchst oder
meinst du jetzt rein von dem, was man zusätzlich dadurch abdecken könnte und was der Akku
kostet, ich will auf jeden Fall einen Akku, da habe ich eine USB fürs gesamte Haus, wenn
der Strom mal ausfällt, funktioniert das überhaupt so wie ich mir das gerade vorstelle, Akku
kannst du nach 3 Jahren wegkloppen, das weiß ich nicht, das müssen wir erstmal gucken,
ob das wirklich so ist, das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen, wann kommt der Tesla gar
nicht, ich werde mir erstmal kein neues Auto kaufen, ich fahre so selten Auto, das lohnt
sich nicht und wenn, hole ich mir was in der Größe, wie ich jetzt habe, aber als Elektroauto
und ihr wisst, ich habe das agilste Auto überhaupt und auch wahrscheinlich eines der
ältesten fahrenden Autos hier von allen im Chat, also mein Auto ist von 2001, ja, in
grün, in grün, gg, gut, also, das wird aber knapp, was passiert denn, was passiert denn,
wenn ich 4500 bestelle, was kostet es, ach so, der Versand kostet 62000 Euro, das ist
aber günstig, bis wann, bis wann gibt es Aliexpress Standard, ok, Aliexpress Standard
geht ganz schön lang, oh, bis 130 oder so, das ist ja ein Schnapper hier, also 2 Stück,
ach komm, das kostet 11 Euro, mir bestelle ich da jetzt 5 Stück von, das ist richtig
nice, ich habe mir so eine RGB Lampe gebaut und da habe ich richtig Spaß dran an dem Ding,
ich wollte mir jetzt noch eine fürs Schlafzimmer bauen, ihr schaut, huge RGB, die sieht man
übrigens gar nicht so krass, die LEDs, das liegt ein bisschen an der iPhone Kamera, 50
Euro für LED, ja, für 5 Stück, 3D gedruckt, ja, ja, bam, so, in den Einkaufswagen, Einkaufswagen
ansehen, Bestellung ist raus, wunderbar, next, muss es mal kurz abhaken, kurz mal den Kram
rausschmeißen, den ich schon habe, ja, wo ich ja immer noch ein bisschen auf der Suche
bin, ist für meine Rollos ein Gurtwickler nennt sich das, aber einen, den ich gescheit
fernsteuern kann, ich habe mal den Versuch gemacht, mit einem, das habe ich auch hier
im Video gezeigt, Moment, aber die sind mir erstens zu teuer und zweitens hat der Hersteller
Firmware gepatcht, dass man die nicht mehr mit Custom Software ansteuern kann, so, und
mein Haus hier hat ja eine Mischung aus, sagen wir mal neuen Rollos, mit, die einfach nur
aus Plastik sind, zum hoch und runter machen, die kann ich auch schon fernsteuern, funktioniert
jetzt schon, aber ich habe noch ein paar Räume, das ist ein paar, ich glaube 5 Räume oder
so noch, die haben noch so einen alten, richtig schweren Holzroller an, du hast die im Haus,
würdest du nicht nochmal machen, warum, also ich mache es auch nicht, weil die haben mich
jetzt schon nicht so ganz überzeugt, die Dinger, ähm, was gefällt dir da nicht, also zumindest
man konnte den fernsteuern mit Custom Software, aber das funktioniert nicht mehr, das haben
die irgendwie gepatcht, so und ich bin jetzt auf der Suche nach irgendwie so einem Gurtwickler,
nennt sich das ja, am besten einen, den man direkt über WLAN, über offene Schnittstellen
ansteuern kann, aber ich fürchte, sowas wird es nicht geben, innerhalb von einem Jahr musste
ich sieben Stück neu konfigurieren, neu konfigurieren oder austauschen, weil sie kaputt waren, so
wir suchen jetzt einfach Gurtwickler, API, sowas, sowas, die haben alle irgendwelche komischen
Drecks Custom-Protokolle, das nervt mich, warum macht keiner nen Motor für nen Rollladen mit
ner Web-API, nimm doch einfach nen elektrisch entbauenen Shelley ein, du meinst, dass der,
das ist eigentlich ne gute Idee, du meinst, dass der Shelley für mich quasi auf, auf
die Tasthoch-Hundertaste drückt oder was, oder wie meinst du das, das find ich jetzt
ne gute Idee, nur neu konfigurieren war aber trotzdem mega aufwander, sagt, echt welche
hast du, mach mal, mach mal einen coolen Vorschlag, was hast du denn für einen, okay, das ist
natürlich Fail, das sind dann richtig olle, fette, große Holz-Rolläden, aber ich mag
die Holz-Rolläden, weil wenn die zu sind, die sind richtig zu und die kannst du auch
von außen nicht hochheben, gerade im Erdgeschoss find ich das richtig gut mit den Holz-Rolläden,
ja musst du jetzt nicht, musst du nicht machen, wenn du es weißt, kannst du ja am nächsten
schrieben oder so posten, genau, by the way, kennt jemand gute Pan-Tilt-Kameras für Indoor,
am besten welche, die keine Apps brauchen dafür, die ich steuern kann, am besten über
einen Webinterface, beziehungsweise die sich noch besser integrieren lassen, am besten
in irgendwie Home Assistant oder per MQTT oder was auch immer und den RTSP Stream haben,
das in Kombination ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach zu finden, die Kameras, die ich
jetzt habe, die können das ja auch nur, weil ich die mit Custom-Firmware geflasht habe,
also ich hab hier aktuell so welche, unter anderem die V2 Wisecam und die hab ich Custom-Firmware
geflasht. So, und da hab ich MQTT-Integration für Pan-Tilt, da hab ich, also nicht mit der,
mit der anderen von denen, da hab ich Möglichkeit, Nacht-Infrarot-LEDs zu kontrollieren, RTSP
Streams, funktioniert wunderbar, aber ich hätte halt gerne sowas vielleicht, ohne
dass ich Custom-Firmware flashen muss und ohne die kacken WLAN-Verbindungen dieser Kameras.
Vielleicht kennt ihr einer von euch was. Ja, die Dinger sind mega teuer und die kannst
du glaub ich auch nicht gescheit steuern, außer über den, ihren Kram. Doch, es gab,
es gab von Shelly eine extra Version für Rollladendinger, aber ich glaub von Shelly
für den Rollladen, die sind für Rollladen Motoren gedacht. Ja, Moment, Drextream, habt
ihr nen Motor oben, den ihr über den Shelly ansteuert oder habt ihr wirklich so nen, so
nen eingebauten Motor-Wickler? Ja, am liebsten wären wir was mit MQTT-Insegrationen, außerdem
kosten die Dinger viel. Ich hätte gerne so irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, 40 Euro Indoor-Kamera,
fertig. Ich glaub das ist alles nicht so, aber Shelly 2.5. Onfif, genau so hieß das,
ich erinnere mich noch dran, stimmt ja. Darüber hab ich das Root-Passwort von meiner Kamera
rausbekommen, was ich dem Hersteller gemeldet hab und der Hersteller hat gesagt, ich soll
mal gefälligst mein Proof of Concept von Github löschen. Ja, so kanns gehen. Ok,
Shelly 2.5 sind gedacht für, das ist auch nur ein Relay zum Schalten, oder? Double Relay
Switch and Shutter-Roller. Ach Moment, Moment, Moment. Das ist ein doppeltes Relay dafür,
dass man hoch und runter drücken kann, weil es ja zwei Tasten hat, eine Taste für hoch
und eine Taste für runter, deswegen brauchst du zwei Relays. Weil ansonsten kannst du das
ja für jedes X beliebige andere auch verwenden. Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, das da
einzubauen, finde ich, ist keine schlechte Sache. Aber welche Gurtwickler habt ihr denn,
im Backstream? Also wie heißen die Dinger denn? Oh, MQTT-Proker, jetzt gehts aber rund
hier. MQTT erste Schritte. Die haben tatsächlich MQTT-Integration, das hätt ich jetzt net
gedacht. Das ist aber Massive Big Brain. Wahnsinn. Aber der Shit ist glaub ich übelst
und teuer, oder? Mac-Adressen-Leak. Okay, wie teuer sind denn die Dinger von den? Zeig
mal her. Cloud, nein, nein, nein, nix Cloud. POE Kameras, nee POE brauch ich gar net. Innenkameras,
Außenkameras, zack, bumm. Da ist bestimmt auch noch China-Chinesen Zeug drin. Das sind
Sachen aus den 80ern, die waren schon bestand, achso. Gut, sollte aber mit jeder anderen
Schicht auch funktionieren. Das Zeug ist aber ordentlich. Meine Güte, was sind denn das
für Preise? Eine Kamera für innen für 200€, eine Indoor-Kamera. Sowas krieg ich von den
China-Chinesen für 30€. Okay, mit ein paar Problemen, aber Alter, 109€, das ist ja...
Das ist 180€ sind, nee, nee. Also das ist schon echt heftig viel. Boah, the fuck. Alter,
nee, das geb ich dafür net aus, nee. Wieso nicht D-Link für 30€? Ja, wenn du D-Link,
also wenn du eine D-Link-Kamera kennst, die den Stream per RTSP liefert, die Pan tilt
kann und am besten steuerbar ist über irgendeine Web-Schnittstelle ohne offizielle App, dann
her damit, bin ich der Erste, der sich so ein Ding kauft. Wir gucken jetzt mal Amazon.
Indoor Pan tilt. Eufy, China-Chinesen-Kram. Integration, okay, zeig mal her. Jaro, der
Jaro-Mart, das hört sich irgendwie fast schon ein bisschen Russisch oder so an. Jaro-Mart.
Jaro-Mart. Also irgendwie klingt das... Was kostet denn ein Jaro-Mart? Jaro-Mart-Eko-Ab,
das ist wahrscheinlich... Jaro-Mart-Eko, Alter. Geiler Name, das Ding. Jaro-Mart. Eufy ist
nicht chinesisch, ist von Anker. Anker ist doch China-Kram. Anker ist China-Chinesen-Krampel,
guck hier. Anker Innovation ist ein China-Chinesen-Hersteller aus Shenzhen. Also im Prinzip das China-Technik-Ding.
Ist es nicht da, wo sie jetzt Nordkoreaner für haben einfliegen lassen, um dort Arbeiten
zu machen, die lebensgefährlich sind, weil die Chinesen das nicht mehr selbst machen
wollen? Ich hab letztens irgendwie sowas gelesen, dass die Chinesen sich ein paar Nordkoreaner
geholt haben, die so verzweifelt waren, weil die Chinesen... Also, dass die jetzt die
Arbeiten machen, die die Chinesen selbst nicht mehr machen wollen, weil sogar die Chinesen
die Arbeiten zu gefährlich sind. Da haben sich die Chinesen gedacht, weißt du was?
Nee, war einfach ein paar Nordkoreaner. Die haben es nötig, die brauchen es. Ah, die
haben da halt keine Schmerzen mit, ne? Juckt das nicht. Ja, aber siehst du das in China-Kram?
Na, ich find den immer noch geil. Gekommnet, der Gekommnet-Mart, Alter. Jaromart. Ok, der
ist vielleicht nicht das schönste, der obendrauf ist. Ich hätt schon gern sowas hier, sowas
hier in der Richtung. Was, weil wir haben ja da, wir haben ja da die Löcher für in
der Wand. Ist eigentlich, ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee, da speicher ich mir mal.
Jaromart. So, guck hier, zum Beispiel so ein TP-Link-Ding. Wäre ich sofort dabei, aber
wenn das eine dieser Dinger nicht kann, kann das schon mal Pan-Tilt. Kann man das schon
mal drehen? Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder? Pan-Tilt, ok, steht ganz groß oben da. So, das heißt
das nächste ist, man kann das nur über die offizielle App steuern. Wir haben bestimmt
keinen RTSP-Stream, da fängt es schon an. Wie konnte man noch mal Kommentare durchsuchen?
Das hier, wie kann man ein RTSP-Leistung auf einer Turbo-Kamera machen? Ist das eine Turbo-Kamera?
Oh, ok. Gut, so, erster Punkt schon mal erfüllt. Nächster Punkt, wie kann ich die Steuerung
machen? Die Steuerung geht wahrscheinlich nur über die Apps. Ich will es ja nicht über
die App machen. Ok, RTSP-Stream geht schon mal, das ist gut. Aber wie kann man die Kamera
machen? Ah, guck mal, man kann die als On-Fif-Kamera hinzufügen. Spricht man doch garantiert nicht
On-Fif aus, oder? Wie sprecht man das aus? On-Fif. So was wie On-Fif?
Ok, das probiere ich vielleicht wirklich mal aus. Turbo-Kamera-Hand-Tilt-On-Fif.
Tatsächlich, das sollte funktionieren. Oh, das haben die erst vor einem Monat gepostet.
Das ist Bleeding-Edge-Technologie hier. Turbo-Kamera-Control. Interessant. Ja, finde ich cool, dass es das
gibt. Vielleicht. Ja, Track-Detect-Movement brauche ich nicht. Dann würde ich sagen,
dann wird es mal Zeit, dass ich mir eine Turbo-Kamera kaufe, um die auszuprobieren. Easy. Turbo-Firmware.
Haben wir doch schon was gefunden, siehste? Also 37 Euro sind mir lieber als 250. Im Stream,
wieso soll ich Woop League machen, oder? Das ist eh bei mir, kommt das ins IoT-WLAN, ohne
dass es irgendwo hin darf. Die wurde storniert ohne Grund. Moment, ich probiere die jetzt
über die App zu kaufen. App, Smartphone, auf Amazon, Turbo, C-200, C-210. Was ist der
Unterschied dazwischen? Best Seller, 32 Euro. Warum findet, Alter, warum findet das immer
was anderes? Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Turbo, C-210 und C-200? Was ist denn
da der Unterschied? Warum steht die Kamera da auf dem Kopf? Die ist älter. Ja gut,
die hat wahrscheinlich schlechtere Auflösung. Okay, ich will nur, die hat kein Two-Way-Audio.
Okay. Die haben anscheinend Probleme damit. Na gut. Automatische Software-Updates gibt
es bei mir nicht. Das Ding ist im IoT-WLAN, da ist nichts mit Two-Way-Audio oder sonst
was. Und das ist, guck dir mal da, da kostet es jetzt die 210,39 Euro und hier kostet
es 37 Euro. Was zum Teufel, wo ist der? Das erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht. Oh,
sind das UK Imports? Gut, UK Imports werden bei mir auch öfters cancelled. Das kenne
ich. UK Imports, das Problem hatte ich auch schon, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Man kann aber hier unten meistens auf neu und gebraucht gehen, aber anscheinend gibt
es da nicht. Warte mal, sie gibt es hier mit diesen Button neu und gebraucht. Brexit,
ja, ich weiß gar nicht, warum die noch drinnen sind. Ich versuche jetzt mal von der App zu
bestellen, so. I know. Ich habe gebyt. Leute, es ist schwieriger als man denkt. Jetzt wollen
sie nicht, dass ich was bestelle. So, jetzt gucke ich mal, your orders, your orders, da
ist er noch drin. Na ja. Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Ah, geil. Oh, Big Brain
Chat, Alter, guckt euch mal wieder an. Der Chat ist wirklich, die ganzen Subs haben sich
gelohnt. Guckt euch das mal an. Jetzt haben wir direkt einen Vergleich. Guck mal, der
Bildsensor von der Alten ist größer. Ihh, 15 FPS, MonkaS. Na gut, man kann bestimmt
Low-Quality Stream machen und das ist dann weniger. Die haben auch integrierte Lautsprecher.
Ah, guck mal, die hat doch integriertes Mikrofon. Ansonsten machen die mehr oder weniger eigentlich
das Gleiche. Das menschliche Auge sieht nur 8 FPS, das stimmt nicht, sind 12. Also ein
großer Unterschied ist das nicht. Equipa. Hat mal einer von euch was bei Equipa bestellt?
Ah, hier ist, hier ist Marketplace angesagt. Marketplace, China, Chinesen. Sag mal, gibt
es nicht noch, ich checke es gerade nicht auf der Amazon-Seite. Es gibt doch normalerweise
hier einen Knopf. Neu und Gebrauch. Ach hier, Osser, Osser, Osser, Sellers on Amazon sind
da. Da haben sie es versteckt jetzt, es ist neu. Ok, das ist anscheinend alles nicht pünktlich
lieferbar hier. Na gut, das würde ich an denen in ihrer Stelle auch so machen, weil wenn
die Bahn Güterverkehr mäßig streikt, wer weiß wann das ankommt. Oh Leute, ich sehe
es gerade, guck mal die Uhr. Guck mal auf die Uhr. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht alles, alles
hier fertig bekommen. Ich habe zu lange geschwätzt. CacWade. Anscheinend braucht man die TP-Link-App
und einen Account um das Ding in Betrieb zu nehmen. Das ist auch noch so ein Ding. Egal,
IoT-Netzwerk regelt.
Ja, aus irgendwelchen Gründen haben die ja mein Outro Song gelöscht. Also Leute, wir
sehen uns. Bis denn. Bis zum nächsten Stream. Macht's gut, bis denn. Betge-Time. Huge Betge,
huge sleep, massive dream. Bis denn, macht's gut.